[Musique]
Véronique prince que l'on retrouve
Michel coge bonsoir bonsoir
lettre à la haine du Journal de Montréal
ce matin Véronique et Michel C de
monsieur Legault adressé à Monsieur
Trudeau deux extraits qu'on vous montre
mesdames et messieurs pour qu'on
comprenne je vous demande dit-il et
critique de prendre de manière urgente
et permanente toutes les mesures
nécessaires afin de répartir les
demandeurs d'asile vers d'autres
provinces et ce sans égard au profit du
demandeur on va reparler Véronique mais
ça veut dire même si il parle français
et pour ce qui est de la négociation
avec les États-Unis pour le tiers pays
sûr dans les meilleurs délais afin
qu'elle s'applique à tous les points
d'entrée pour revoir l'entente donc
dit-il au Canada qu'il soit régulier ou
irréguliers le chemin Roxane devra être
fermé un jour qu'on le veuille ou non
Véronique première question à qui
s'adressait vraiment la lettre O au
Québécois au Canadien monsieur Trudeau à
tout le monde en fait parce que c'est
une stratégie de communication qui est
empruntée par n'importe quel
gouvernement qui est le moindrement
expérimenté en communication
gouvernementale c'est-à-dire que dans
les faits il répète pratiquement la même
chose que qu'il a déjà dit monsieur
Legault devant les médias combien de
fois à ce panel on a joué des extraits
là en écrivant une lettre les écrits
restent donc déjà là il y a un caractère
qui est beaucoup plus officiel puis
regarder la séquence en fait il la coule
dans un média un seul au début un lundi
matin en se disant les autres médias
vont le reprendre ça va faire boule de
neige monsieur Lego aujourd'hui n'était
pas disponible pour commenter pourquoi
parce qu'il a envoyé ses officiers le
ministre Roberge la vis première
ministre Geneviève Guilbaud demain il va
être disponible pour commenter parce que
ça siège au parlement donc il va être
capable d'en parler au moins sur deux
jours si fois plus et reprendre le
contrôle de son agenda parce que la
semaine dernière et même l'autre d'avant
il se faisait accuser un peu de molles
par rapport à Justin Trudeau avec la
question des transferts en santé donc là
au contraire il reprend la pôle en
disant ben cette fois-ci j'ai dit j'agis
avec fermeté je dis que ça peut vraiment
plus fonctionner le chemin Roxane et
espère pouvoir comme ça en parler toute
la semaine ça c'est le côté très
politique mais d'un autre côté monsieur
Legault ne prêche pas dans le désert non
plus là parce qu'il ajoute sa voix à
celle de beaucoup d'autres les
organismes qui déjà ont commencé à
mettre de la pression les Québécois
aussi qui ont commencé à en mettre et là
ça a des échos dans d'autres provinces
parce que denisking avait du
presse-édouard puis blend X au
Nouveau-Brunswick on commençait à sortir
en disant ouais c'est vrai que c'est un
enjeu national finalement ça concerne
pas juste le Québec donc bien ficeler
tout ça Véronique c'est intéressant
Michel C avant d'entendre monsieur
auberge comment vous avez vos premières
réactions vous avez lu ça ce matin et
tôt cette lettre à monsieur Legault
très bien fonctionner puis Véronique a
fait tout le travail alors je répète pas
ce qu'elle me dit mais quand on voit que
les organismes qui a des réfugiés disent
on est à bout là il y a personne qui va
contester ce monsieur de Gaultier
actuellement alors ça c'est une chose
j'ai été très surpris d'avoir les
réactions des deux premiers ministres
qu'on a entendu plutôt dans l'émission
oui c'est un enjeu national on doit
faire notre part on a des problèmes de
logement mais il faut qu'on fasse notre
part ça
s'il ne gagne que ça c'est le mot
l'ouverture des autres premiers
ministres ça va être énorme ça c'est
l'autre chose ce qui risque de pas se
passer par exemple c'est quand tu dis
bon on va faire un jour ou l'autre je
mets Roxane il vous appellera
le président des États-Unis vient à
savoir les discussions sont faites
d'avance on s'entend sur l'agenda c'est
réglé comme pas bien musique et je suis
sûr que le chemin Roxane est très très
haut d'un priorité Joe Biden et bien
franchement pas très très haut
d'ailleurs priorité de Monsieur Trudeau
ok je vais vous faire entendre les
extraits puis ensuite on va faire comme
s'il y avait une entente avec Washington
on va expliquer aux gens ce qu'on
explique jamais qu'est-ce que ça ferait
de changer l'entente puis surtout les
points de passage irréguliers réguliers
mais d'abord monsieur Roberge et les
deux premiers ministres dont on vient de
parler
donc on veut que formellement comme un
Trudeau s'engage à payer ses frais là on
veut rassurer les Québécois alors que
c'est pas eux qui vont assumer cette
facture là et on veut aussi un
engagement formel à ce que il y a de
l'équité au Canada c'est pas normal
qu'en 2022 c'est le Québec qui accueilli
99% des gens qui sont passés par Roxane
ce qu'on veut c'est que l'entente soit
renégocié parce que ça a pas de bon sens
que le gouvernement fédéral est
complètement perdu le contrôle de sa
frontière
une question nationale du blinings donc
c'est ce que vous disiez Michel et
Véronique donc là-dessus leur a réussi à
recadrer ce débat là pas uniquement
comme un débat Québec puis Québec avec
les Québécois mais un débat canadien sur
toute la frontière bon s'il y avait une
entente monsieur Trudeau avant Noël dans
les entrevues de fin d'année nous avait
dit
on souhaiterait que s'applique au chemin
Roxane la même logique s'applique dans
une douane régulière c'est à dire qu'on
pourrait refouler les gens qui arrivent
puisqu'ils sont dans un pays tiers les
États-Unis qui est sécuritaire est-ce
que c'est ça qu'on a en tête qu'on parle
d'entendre possible Michel Debard
c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose comme
ça qu'on a en tête la difficulté c'est
d'abord pourquoi les américains qui
l'entente
du Canada pour le rappeler pas longtemps
après le 11 septembre parce qu'on
craignait des des mouvements de
population importants c'est entente là
le Canada peut
mettre fin par une simple lettre envoyée
à Washington la réalité des choses c'est
que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
il y a quoi 5000 km de frontière entre
les deux
si nous sommes
[Musique]
la bande c'est ce qu'ils faisaient cette
faire et qu'ils aimeraient faire mais
avant que ça se rende au président des
États-Unis bon ben c'est ça et puis ils
vont faire des appels au maire de New
York ça a été fait aussi et puis ça bon
en espérant que peut-être que Joe Biden
finisse par en entendre parler mais dans
les faits la pression il la mette sur
Justin Trudeau puis quand les autres
provinces ajoutent leur voix comme ça
c'est sûr que Justin Trudeau n'aura pas
le choix d'en parler tantôt Michel
disait peut-être que ça va être loin
dans la liste des priorités le chemin
Roxane dans les échanges que Justin
Trudeau à avoir avec Joe Biden parce que
Québec essaie de faire c'est de le faire
augmenter dans les priorités puis si
Justin Trudeau le fait pas il va s'en
faire parler par les Québécois donc
c'est un petit peu la logique que
derrière tout ça mais en même temps
rappelez-vous Michel un ministre fédéral
avait dit on est à l'entente est à
portée de main c'est tout est presque
fait donc il n'avait pas uniquement que
fabuler c'est qu'il y a il y a un
processus politique à Washington qui
fait que il faut que le président même
si lui est d'accord pour signer un
Trudeau il faut qu'il faut qu'il rentre
chez arrières là
et c'est compliqué ces choses là et
c'est long à négocier et d'autre part
d'une part tu montes le sait là les
Américains
très bien mais la frontière et les
poreuse cette frontière-là à quoi
s'abîme qu'il arrête ou c'est mettre
entre le Canada
et ça c'est le problème qu'on risque
d'avoir même si les douaniers avaient le
pouvoir de dire non vous n'êtes pas
réfugié rester aux États-Unis là on va
s'engagerait dans une dans des passes de
frontières illégales compte complètement
avec des façons de choses comme ça
est-ce que on veut aller là le Canada ne
veut pas aller là justement très bien il
reste trois minutes on va prendre un
sujet plus léger si si vous permettez
est-ce qu'on ajoute un congé férié au
Québec ces jours fériés partout pays
sauf Québec et Terre Neuve aujourd'hui
les on a vu le tableau tout à l'heure
général nous la présenter on peut le
voir il y a 9 jours fériés en Ontario 8
au Québec monsieur Legault Véronique de
mémoire était pas très chaud à l'idée
d'ajouter un jour férié absolument pas
oublier ça si vous voulez
au Québec non parce que François Legault
il l'a dit souvent son obsession c'est
de réduire le corps de richesse avec
l'Ontario et pour ça il faut augmenter
la productivité le nombre d'heures
travaillées notamment évidemment ça peut
se faire en ajoutant plus de
travailleurs ça peut se faire en
allongeant la semaine c'est sûr que la
productivité c'est un des indicateurs de
l'économie il y en a d'autres ça peut
être la robotisation etc mais pour
l'instant bref la productivité elle
n'est pas assez grande à son goût pour
ajouter un congé férié et je me rappelle
que la question lui avait été posée pour
le 21 juin qui est la Journée nationale
des peuples autochtones puis il avait
dit non il s'était fait énormément
critiquer pour ça alors si là à dire oui
un jour ce sera pas pour la journée de
la famille ça sera davantage peut-être
pour la journée nationale des peuples
autochtones
est un comptable et réagit en comptable
mais il y avait des parents entre autres
au Québec qui disaient la sensible
l'année un congé ce serait peut-être pas
bête qui s'appelle le relâche scolaire
et ça existe ailleurs aussi le Market et
tout ça mais pourquoi ne pas dire que le
lundi du début de la semaine de relance
les parents très bien contents de
quelque chose comme ça on est pas obligé
que ça soit
de 3e le 10 février la commande
aux États-Unis au Canada mais ça peut
être autre chose on peut faire notre
distinction québécoise de cette façon là
mais la semaine de relâche est quelque
chose d'assez gros pour les parents
pourquoi ne pas dire que on va au moins
dire une journée de cette semaine de
relâche là sera prier pour tout le monde
c'est la modeste suggestion que je ferai
aujourd'hui bon ben mais Véronique vous
dites ne retenez pas votre souffle
parce qu'en fait
qu'il fut une époque ou quand François
Legault était
nation puis se définissait comme
la taxe était le parti des familles Ben
peut-être qu'à ce moment-là ça aurait pu
se retrouver dans les promesses de la
CAQ à l'époque mais aujourd'hui la façon
dont François Legault se définit c'est
le développeur économique alors pour
ceux qui ajouteront pas une journée
férié pour augmenter comme je disais la
productivité on enverra le même genre
modèle japonais il y en a plein levier
avec Gérald tout à l'heure et ils en ont
beaucoup plus que nous au Japon ils
travaillent beaucoup merci beaucoup à
vous deux bonne soirée au revoir merci à
très bientôt pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI